[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, and welcome
to episode number
51 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am good.
Thank you, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Very happy to have
someone from our team
that I really just assume
we had interviewed before
but happens to be we didn't yet.
MARK MANDEL: No, we're having
Sandeep Dinesh on the show.
He is a great teammate
and representative
of the Developer Advocate Team.
And he's joining us today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and we're going
to be talking about a game.
We're going to be talking about
Simon Says, which is apparently
something that you two work
together on building, mixing,
IoT, and Kubernetes, and stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that's pretty accurate.
Yeah, I'll go with that.
That's a good teaser.
People should listen.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is really fun,
and I personally have seen what
the demo of what the game looks
like.
It's lots of fun.
MARK MANDEL: It is lots of fun.
It's one of my favorite talks,
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and then at the end
we'll have a question
of the week, as always.
And this time, we don't
know what happened, so--
MARK MANDEL: We could
have a mystery guest.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Who knows?
Who knows?
So before all of this, let's
start with the cool things
of the week.
And this week, as usual,
we have more than one.
We actually have two.
And the first one
is regarding IAM.
So we had an episode on IAM,
Identity and Access Management.
What are the needs on this?
MARK MANDEL: So one
thing that's really cool
that's new is an
organizational resource.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So
it's a resource that
sits above projects,
which means, then,
that you can actually set owners
for projects at an organization
level.
So say if you do something
like only set one person
as the owner for a project,
which you should not do,
and that person say, leaves that
company, you could get stuck.
So you can set up
organization owners,
so anyone who's part of the
organization level, that's
great.
And it also means
you can do things
like, I've got people who should
be developers on a project.
So they should then be able
to access all the developer
resources, say the
developer projects,
but maybe not certain
other projects
that are for network admins
or completely other things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know
that there's a very good use
case for this, which is if
you have people managing
only the finance side of it,
being able to manage billing
for all the projects in an
organization, that totally
makes sense.
If you need to do
things like this,
that is probably the
easiest way to do it now.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And the other
one, the other piece of news
is something that you are
incredibly excited about.
You were jumping around
the studio a minute ago.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I'm a little excited.
Oh, wow, yeah, I'm so excited.
So if anyone does
any game development,
Unity is a very, very popular
game engine and development
environment for people
to build games in.
Firebase, which we've had on
the podcast more than once,
literally-- well, as
we were recording,
announced and launched the
Unity plugins for Firebase.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: This
is particularly cool
because previously, there was
an open source plugin for just
a real-time database,
but now we've
had support for analytics,
authentication, invites
and dynamic links, Cloud
Messaging, remote config,
and the real-time database.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow, nice.
MARK MANDEL: So you basically
have the full suite there.
It's pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice,
just for the people
that don't know much
what this means,
what-- you develop
some stuff on Unity.
What do you think this
will be exciting for?
MARK MANDEL: So I think it is
exciting-- so authentications,
if you want standard OAuth
authentication, for GItHub,
Twitter, or stuff like that--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's huge.
MARK MANDEL: And just making
that super, super simple to do.
Analytics is free, so you can
plug in Firebase Analytics
and use them for as
much as you like.
Real-time database,
yeah, so if you
want to build turn-based
games or card-based games,
stuff like that, or
even just matchmaking.
A lot of companies use
Firebase for matchmaking
without having to worry
about socket communication
or transport protocols
or anything like that.
Firebase is a great backend
as a service for doing that.
And there's all sorts
of other fun things
you can definitely
do in there, as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Personally,
just with the authentication
part of it, I'm just happy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, who wants
to write OAuth handlers?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that is awesome.
Cool, so I think it's
time to go talk to Sandeep
and our other guest, yourself.
MARK MANDEL: Which is me.
Yeah, let's go talk to myself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm very happy
to walk home today Sandeep
Dinesh, fellow Developer
Advocate from the Google Cloud
Platform team.
Hi, how are you doing?
SANDEEP DINESH: Awesome, finally
happy to be on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, finally.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's great to have you.
SANDEEP DINESH:
I'm finally happy.
I haven't been happy
since this moment.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're going
to be talking about something
pretty cool that you both
actually worked together,
right, which is Simon Says?
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Could
you tell a little bit,
for the people that are
not American and have not
watched teenager movies,
what is Simon Says?
SANDEEP DINESH: Yes, so Simon
Says, or Simon as it's called,
is a game from the '70s or '80s.
I'm not sure why in the
'70s-- before my time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: '79,
'78, I think it came out.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so
it's a pretty simple game.
It's a box, and it has
four different buttons
with four different colors.
And it will light up one color,
and then it's a memory game,
so you press that color.
And then it lights
up two colors,
and you press those two colors.
And then three, and then
four, and then as many as you
can until you lose, right?
There's no winning this game.
It's a great--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
no winning this game.
SANDEEP DINESH: Great game
that you can only lose.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it was all--
this is basically my childhood
before there were things like
Sega or Nintendo or anything.
I was like, OK red.
Red, yellow.
Red, yellow, red.
Red, yellow, red, blue.
And so on so forth.
SANDEEP DINESH: Hours
of entertainment.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
why are we talking about it?
MARK MANDEL: So Sandeep and I
were talking at a conference--
oh, wow, about a year
ago at least now.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah,
almost a year ago.
MARK MANDEL: --called Ubiquity,
which was an IoT conference.
And we got pushed together into
building a project together.
And we came up with
this idea for Simon,
but we wanted to make
Simon multiplayer
and massively
scalable multiplayer.
SANDEEP DINESH: So
it's interesting.
I think I was going
to give an IoT talk,
and then you were going
to give a container talk.
And then we're like, let's do--
MARK MANDEL: Together!
SANDEEP DINESH: A
big talk together.
And then we said, what can we
do with containers, and IoT,
and real-time, and all
these buzzwordy stuff?
Can we do something that
puts it all together, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so we
came up with the idea.
I think, actually, you came
up with the idea-- credit
where credit's due-- of
taking Simon Says and saying,
OK, let's make this
playable over the internet.
So just to understand before we
get on how you actually build
this, how does one play it?
What is the mechanics
of the game?
SANDEEP DINESH: The
multiplayer version?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
SANDEEP DINESH:
Yeah, so let's say me
and Mark are playing, right.
I will say, green.
So I'll pick the first
color, and I'll pick green.
Now on Mark's device or
screen, it'll show up green.
And so now he presses green, and
then he picks the next color.
So it would be
green, yellow, right?
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
And then, so I send it to you.
SANDEEP DINESH: And then
it comes to me, and then
on my screen green, yellow.
And then I can go
green, yellow, red.
And then it goes
to Mark's screen.
And so we just keep
adding an additional color
until someone loses.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
OK, so it is online,
and there's many players.
But in any given match,
there's only two players.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, OK.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about how you built this.
We're on Google Cloud
Platform Podcast,
so I'm assuming that
the Cloud is involved?
SANDEEP DINESH:
Yeah, a little bit.
Little bit.
MARK MANDEL: Little bit.
SANDEEP DINESH:
Surprisingly, a little bit.
MARK MANDEL: So first thing that
we decided we were going to do
was to talk about how we
wanted this to communicate.
Like Sandeep said, real-time
is really important.
So if I press the color
red on my machine,
it should show up
red on his machine
in relatively real-time.
We don't want latency
to be an issue.
What other criteria did we have?
I think security was a big
concern for us, obviously.
Hacking Simon Says.
SANDEEP DINESH: Simon
Says is the number
one most hacked game.
It's a--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's a big issue.
MARK MANDEL: That's
the a big issue.
SANDEEP DINESH:
A very big issue.
We also wanted
multiple devices to be
able to support Simon
Says because there's
an IoT aspect to it.
So it has to work
on physical devices.
We wanted it to work on phones.
We wanted it to work
on the computer.
It has to work in the cloud.
It has to work on all of
these different platforms
in a seamless experience, right?
If I'm playing on
the phone, I should
be able to play someone
on an IoT device.
I shouldn't be locked
into playing only someone
else on a phone, right.
So that was another
big criteria for us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think
it's actually interesting,
because I wanted
to build something
on Android because hardware
stuff terrifies me.
And I think I'm going to set
myself on fire, whereas you
wanted to build this crazy
box with buttons and wires
and things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is interesting.
So you're using
different clients.
One is an IoT stuff,
which I've actually seen.
It looks like your normal lunch
bucket with buttons on top.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so that's
actually a really long story.
Originally, I went and
bought a real Simon Says
from the '80s from the store.
And I took it apart,
and I soldered it,
and I put Ardruino in it.
And it was so unreliable
that I eventually
ended up drilling
buttons into it
because who knew that the old
Simon Says used actual buttons?
The new one uses these touch
sensitive capacitive things
that are not reliable at all.
And eventually it turned to a
lunch box with buttons, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice, so
one runs Android with Java.
The other one is running--
SANDEEP DINESH:
Node.js, actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Node.js
on what platform?
SANDEEP DINESH: So
we're actually running
an Arduino, which runs C code.
It's talking a protocol called
Fermata, which is basically,
you can send commands up and
down a serial port to USB.
And then a computer
runs the Node.js code
and actually communicates
with the Arduino.
So this can be a Raspberry
Pi or a fully fledged laptop.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, what
other clients do we have?
Do we have iOS or--
MARK MANDEL: So actually,
when we built this thing,
we've had several team
members commit to it, as well.
So not only is there a
Java Android one, one
of our teammates, [? Mette, ?]
built a Java command line
client.
So you can interact
within the command line.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And
I think, Sandeep,
you built the Node
web one, as well.
SANDEEP DINESH:
Right, so we built
one that works on the
web with the Node server,
which is pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So the interesting
thing now is OK,
so you have all of these
different custon-- all
of these different
clients, right,
that are using
different technologies.
How do you make them
communicate correctly?
How do you do this?
MARK MANDEL: So it's
probably also worth
noting that the backend
servers is written
in your favorite language.
SANDEEP DINESH: Python.
MARK MANDEL: Written in Go.
SANDEEP DINESH: Oh, sorry.
MARK MANDEL: So, yeah, I
also wrote the backend server
to allow for all
the matchmaking,
putting players together so
that they could play games
together, as well as the
game code in and of itself.
And these all talk seamlessly
with all the clients,
which is pretty cool.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yep, so I
think we have a few choices.
We could have used web
sockets, or Firebase, or things
like that.
But we ended up picking gRPC
because it had the widest
array of support for
all these clients
without having to deal
with a bunch of hacks.
And I think it was just
very stable and surprisingly
easy to get it to all
work, even though we're
programming in four or
five different languages.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we've done
previous episodes on gRPC,
but the cool thing about gRPC,
if you haven't listened to it,
is you write this thing
called a proto file, which
defines the data that goes up
and down the stream, and also
the services.
So basically these RPCs,
or remote procedure
calls that you can
call, and then it
generates a bunch
of code for you
that's idiomatic to the
language that you're writing in.
So whether it's
Node or Go or Java,
and what's really
cool about that is,
yes, Sandeep and I sat down.
We were like, all right,
how does this work?
Let's write our
proto file, work out
how this thing works, and then
once we had the proto file,
we just split up and went off
and built our own clients.
SANDEEP DINESH: You
can't put us in a room
for more than 20 minutes without
us killing each other, so.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, this is going
to be a hard episode to record.
So the next question
is, obviously,
since you're using
protocol buffers,
one of the coolest things
about protocol buffers
is that it actually uses HTTP/2,
so it makes things way faster.
Is this something
that was going on that
worked in every single of the
platforms that you were using?
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah.
I think I've done
demos where I've
given this over 2G
connections because you're
in the middle of
somewhere, and you
don't have a WiFi connection
to your phone or something
like that.
And it's worked
surprisingly well, right.
Every time you
press that button,
it goes all the way to the
server in a Google data center,
and then comes all the way back
on another different internet
connection to the other device.
And it's almost instantaneous,
which is pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we actually
we deliberately wrote it
that way to make
life easier for us,
and also because
it's a cool demo
to have it-- once you click
a button for it to light up,
it actually gets a
light up message.
So there's a button
press message
that goes all way back
and then a light up
message that comes
back again, which
is not to say you have
to do it that way,
but that's just how we did it.
And yeah, I've done similar
things, where it's like,
yeah, I've got a
mobile connection,
and I just push the
button, and it comes back.
You're talking hundreds
milliseconds, if that.
SANDEEP DINESH: I think the
gRPC bidirectional streaming,
the latency's very low,
which is pretty nice for us.
MARK MANDEL: And it's
a binary protocol,
so it's really tiny going
over the wire, which
makes things great.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah,
we're sending a few bytes,
right, just the color.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So let's talk
about that a little bit more
because-- so there's
many ways you can do it
so the communication
is as fast as possible.
And the obvious
one, since you're
having IoT devices that do not
necessarily have a public IP,
could be the polling.
But you mentioned
bidirectional streaming.
Could you talk a
little bit about that?
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so gRPC,
one of the really cool things,
I think, that me and
Mark really like a lot,
is the bidirectional streaming.
So with this, you can
send, asynchronously,
from the client to the server
or from the server to the client
without having to do polling
or any of these typical very
compute heavy tasks, right.
So it's very, very lightweight.
And the really cool
thing, I think,
about the bidirectional stream
is once that stream is open,
you don't have to send
headers back and forth.
You just send the raw
data, and because it's one
canonical stream, it's easy.
MARK MANDEL: It's really easy.
SANDEEP DINESH: I don't know
what the word for it is.
MARK MANDEL: No, easy is great.
No, but and I think it's-- that
is one of the things I like
about gRPC.
And the flexibility
that you have there,
you could just send
synchronous RPC calls.
I send you some parameters.
You send me back
a response, yay.
But then you can stream
data backwards and forwards.
And for something like this,
where we're making a game,
it's such a nice fit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool,
so now we can understand
how all the clients work.
What about the servers?
We said it was running Node.js?
SANDEEP DINESH: No, the
server is running Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Ah
sorry, it was running Go.
I'm mixing my stuff already.
So--
SANDEEP DINESH: I know you
love Node.js, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know, I love
it so much, almost as much as,
yeah.
So what platform was it running?
Was it App Engine,
Compute Engine?
MARK MANDEL: So
we went with GKE.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: So--
SANDEEP DINESH:
Container Engine.
Container Engine,
for a few reasons,
one of which is
gRPC's supported on Kubernetes.
But it also allows us to scale
nicely, because containers
in Kubernetes.
It worked out really well,
so it's actually noting.
We never actually sat
down, and we were like, oh,
there's a bug with data
going from Node to Go
or-- that was never an issue.
That never-- it was
always like, oh, there's
something wrong with
my code or something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
SANDEEP DINESH:
Yeah, we were using
Redis readings for the caching
layer, for the persistence,
right.
And that works perfectly in
Kubernetes, very easy to scale.
And then our Go code
that you wrote also
can scale up and down.
And it's very easy because
we used the TCP load balancer
on Google Cloud so that
gRPC connection just finds
the server and connects to it.
It's pretty straightforward.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so you can run
five instances of the server,
2,000, 200, whatever you like.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so let's talk
a little bit about the Redis
instances that you had.
How many did you have?
Did you have one?
Did you have it
run in a container?
MARK MANDEL: For demo
purposes, I just run the one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Was it
running on a container?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so I run
it, one, as a container.
There's no reason why you
couldn't have a cluster.
Basically, we use it
for some persistence
and basically for inner
container communication.
There's a [INAUDIBLE]
mechanism inside Redis.
So if you started a
game-- so basically,
if one player is connected
to one container,
one player is connected
to another container,
it allows that information
to flow between them,
say this is what's happening.
SANDEEP DINESH:
Yeah, and we could
have used data store,
or pub/sub, or something
like that.
But I think another
goal of this project
was to keep it 100%
open source, right.
So that was very
important for us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and that
worked that worked really,
really well.
But yeah, so you could run a
huge Redis cluster if you want.
We keep it really simple.
I don't even think
we're using data volumes
to keep it persistent storage.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that was the next question
that I was going to ask.
What happens if one of
those containers dies?
MARK MANDEL: So
right now, it resets.
Yes, completely that's-- for
demo purposes, that's fine.
But yeah, if you were going
to run this as a real game
that people would
play all the time,
you would use data volumes.
SANDEEP DINESH: Here's an
actual interesting fact.
I checked the life
of our cluster,
and it's pretty much been
the same containers running
for the past 200-plus days--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
SANDEEP DINESH:
--without any downtime.
And I even upgraded the cluster
from 1.2 to 1.4, and it was--
MARK MANDEL: It was fine.
SANDEEP DINESH:
It was perfectly,
it just restarted the
pods, and it was all fine.
That's amazing, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is pretty amazing, wow.
So we've talked a little bit
about all the easy things,
like gRPC is amazing and
makes your life easier.
Kubernetes makes it
scale very easily,
and containers, developing
on containers is so nice.
What about the hard parts?
What is something
that you learned
or something that
you wish you knew
before you started doing this?
SANDEEP DINESH: So
one interesting thing
is we used gRPC before
the 1.0 release.
And it was much harder
to use back then.
I think there's a lot of bugs.
I talked to the team
being like, hey,
the Node.js package
doesn't compile.
They're like, oh, don't worry.
It'll compile next week.
And I'm like, OK, I'll
wait till next week.
And then it compiled
next week, which is fine.
With the 1.0, it's
much more stable.
So I don't think people run
into those problems anymore.
But it was a lot of fun
interacting with that team
and really, hey, look,
we have a problem here.
And then they're
immediately on it,
which was a nice experience.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, at the
time, installation of protoc,
you had the compilers for
source and all that stuff.
Now it's so much easier.
By the time this
episode comes out,
I will have updated I think all
the server code to gRPC 1.0,
so that'll be good.
There's so much.
Yeah, it's so much easier.
I can just download a release
of protoc, for example.
That's the tool used to generate
code more often than not.
I'm trying to think
of other challenges.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, I
think one challenge for me--
I actually wrote a
blog post about this.
When I usually do
development nowadays,
I do it in Docker because
it makes it a lot easier.
Downloading protoc and
compiling and all that stuff
was simplified using Docker.
But because it was IoT, I
had physical hardware plugged
into my Mac.
And so I've been doing
all of IoT development
on Windows natively.
And it's a lot-- it's a very
nice experience on Windows.
You can install the driver.
It all works.
On Mac, I felt the USB drivers
were a little bit more flaky.
And then when you add Docker
to that mix, man, that was fun.
So I had to do weird things
like expose the USB device and--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
SANDEEP DINESH: --protected
mode and things like that.
And I wrote a blog post on
how to do Arduino development
on Docker because
you have to use,
basically, privileged mode to
access the raw USB drivers,
right?
And then you had to mount
it into the VirtualBox
machine that's running Linux on
your Mac that's running Docker,
right.
So it's 10 steps
to get it to work,
but it was pretty interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think that
sounds incredibly painful,
actually.
SANDEEP DINESH: Interesting
is the word you use.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, OK.
MARK MANDEL: I think for me, it
was working on the server code.
I'd written a huge
number of tests
to get it to work
right, but as soon
as you put something production,
the best laid plans and all
that stuff.
But I think when
I first wrote it,
I didn't have as much logging
as I probably should have done.
Then went back, and
I logged everything.
And it made things
so much simpler
to actually see what was
going on inside a game.
Because yeah, you're dealing
with threading, right.
One person joins, another person
joins, a third person joins,
who gets match made, why
do they get match made?
Do things go funny?
SANDEEP DINESH: I remember
you made that little mock
for the server, and that's,
basically, when you join,
you immediately win.
And was like, I'm
winning so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I'm actually curious
about-- there's a talk
that Andrew Gerrand gave.
It's about Go, done
a long time ago.
And it was about how to
do matchmaking in Go.
And it is complicated,
the way they do it.
It's juggling around
with channels,
which is a beautiful thing
to do, but it's complicated.
I was curious about
how did you do it?
Was it hard to do it,
taking into account that you
had gRPC and so many
different connections
going on at the same time?
MARK MANDEL: Pretty
much, we lean on Redis.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, cool.
MARK MANDEL: So Redis has got
lists that you can atomically
push and pull from.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
so you just said,
give me the two next ones?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, pop one off,
and then is there one there?
No, wait.
And then is this
another one now?
Yeah, cool.
It makes things really simple.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Have you
considered adding a bot?
SANDEEP DINESH: So if you wanted
to play Simon Says with a bot,
that's the most basic
thing in the world.
MARK MANDEL: It would
be hard to lose.
Or you'd never win.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah,
you could add a bot,
hen you could just
script a-- it would just
be another client, right.
So it'd just be another client--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That'd
be an interesting thing.
SANDEEP DINESH: AI,
i.e., pick a color.
And it has infinite memory,
so you can't really lose to--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That'd
be an interesting--
MARK MANDEL: But it'd be
a cool project, though.
SANDEEP DINESH: It'd be fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it'd be cool.
SANDEEP DINESH: I
think, for any listeners
out there, if you want to
build a bot and give us a PR.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, maybe
a bot in a language
we don't have yet, considering
gRPC does support 10 languages.
So that would be
really, really cool.
SANDEEP DINESH: .NET, Ruby.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That'd
be a very cool demo.
So you mentioned that the
code is open source already.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, so
we'll have a link to the repo
in the show notes, obviously.
And what is the cool things
that you've learned doing this?
Not the things that you were
like, oh, man that was painful.
Or sorry, that was interesting.
But more like, oh, this is cool.
Is there any of those
things that you remember?
SANDEEP DINESH: So for me,
it was my first IoT project
with Node.js So
using Johnny-Five,
I think, it's a really
cool open source library.
If you're a
JavaScript developer,
and you want to mess with
IoT, you just literally
plug in your
Arduino, and then you
can write JavaScript code to
control your devices instead
of trying to write C.
So I wrote C for
a very long time.
I had a startup that
was doing IoT stuff.
And you can shoot yourself
in the foot so easily, right,
buffer overflow
and out of memory.
And you only have so much
room on those devices.
But with Johnny-Five,
it was just
so nice to write IoT
code in JavaScript.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is probably worth
mentioning that we interviewed,
a long time ago-- that
was on February 3, so
super long time ago-- we
interviewed Jen Tong,
another developer advocate
from the Google Cloud
Platform Podcast,
and not from the
Google Cloud Platform,
sorry, now the podcast.
And he also talked
about Johnny-Five
and how it is such a good way
to get started doing IoT stuff.
So we have a link to
that episode, too.
It's episode number 11.
MARK MANDEL: I think for me,
actually, I hadn't had a chance
to play with Redis before.
I've known a lot
of people who I've
known who have used
it and been huge fans.
And I never had a chance to
really, really play with it.
SANDEEP DINESH:
Yeah, this is cool.
MARK MANDEL: And I was
like, this is really cool.
Yeah, really just being able
to manipulate data structures
online, or basically via an API.
I don't have to worry
about how they work
and be able to access them from
multiple places was hugely,
hugely powerful.
And yeah, like I
was talking about,
made matchmaking
super, super simple.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, for me, one
of my favorite things
of Redis is the fact
that you have very simple
atomic operations, like append
to a list, which sounds obvious,
but once you can actually
do that, everything changes,
because you don't need
to fetch the value, add one,
put back, making [INAUDIBLE],
same transaction,
stuff like that.
That is pretty awesome,
yep, that's true.
So one of the clients
mentioned was a web client?
And as far as I know, gRPC
doesn't work for web stuff.
SANDEEP DINESH:
That's right, yeah.
So that's actually
very interesting.
So gRPC does not
work on the web,
right, so it works on Node.js
JavaScript but not web
JavaScript.
I think it's because
the browsers don't
expose the HTTP/2 functionality
to JavaScript yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is pretty impressive.
The browsers are the one
that don't support HTTP/2.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so the
JavaScript on the browsers
don't support the native HTTP/2
streaming and things like that.
It's necessary for gRPC.
So the funny thing is we
had to build a gateway
to translate the gRPC
calls into web sockets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
SANDEEP DINESH: So
it's very simple.
So I used Socket.IO
and a Node.js server.
And basically, whenever
the gRPC call came in,
I just convert it to a
WebSocket on Socket.IO,
send it to the front end that's
listening to that WebSocket
and then sending it back, right.
So just a little gateway.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
Socket.IO is a library?
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so
it's a library for Node.js
that makes WebSockets
easier than without it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And you're running the library
as a standalone container,
or is it part of the server, or?
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, so this
is another client, right.
So I'm running it on my
local machine, actually.
And then just going to
localhost to run the game.
And you can easily
run this on the web
and put it on the server.
I think we could just make
it into another container.
We're just--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that'd be good.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, that'd
be a good thing to do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it actually
would be a really good thing
to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
would make sense.
Otherwise, if I wanted
use it from my browser,
I'd need to run also--
SANDEEP DINESH: Run Node.js
on your machine, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wow.
OK, yeah, no, there's better
way to-- Are you sure?
Oh, but that is an
interesting thing,
to find that there's actually
already a-- basically a library
that you say, hey, this
is gRPC on one side.
This--
SANDEEP DINESH: Well, it's
not-- so I wrote it myself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Is
that open source, too?
SANDEEP DINESH: That
is also open source.
It's on our repo.
And it came up-- there
was part of the actual--
there's just one
monolithic node client.
And that did both
command line it.
It did Arduino.
And it did the web.
And then when we
open sourced it,
we split it up into
smaller projects, which
is why we never got
the idea of running it
in a container on
Kubernetes, which
would make a lot of sense.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, yeah, I really
thought you would say, oh,
yeah, it runs on Kubernetes.
Would make sense, but OK, cool.
So we are running out of time,
but is there anything else,
any other topic that
we have not covered
that you'd like to mention?
MARK MANDEL: I'll talk a
little bit about load balancing
because it's a topic that
comes up with gRPC a lot.
The nice thing about how
we implemented this for us
is that we have
short-lived games,
and that's the
single connection.
And once a game is
over, it disconnects.
So there's things you can
do with load balancing
with gRPC that can be
a little complicated,
depending on what platform
you're on and how you do them.
But for us, it was very
simple because we're like, oh,
somebody's going to play a game.
Once the game is over, they'll
disconnect to the next person
who comes in.
Or the time they want to
play, they reconnect again
and they can play
a whole new game,
but it may be
different container.
They're not stuck on
a single container
because you have a
single connection.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, I think--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that is interesting.
So what you're saying is that
if a container is running
the game, if that
container died,
the connection would disappear,
so the game is interrupted.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, the game
would interrupt at that point.
MARK MANDEL: Whenever you
tried to connect again,
you would never go
to the wrong pod.
You would just
connect to whatever
pod is running because
Kubernetes handles that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah yeah.
It connects to whichever pod,
and then it would matchmake you
all over again.
And then you would
rejoin a whole new game.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Did you ever consider
trying to make it
so it actually if a
Docker container dies,
nothing bad happens?
Is that even doable?
MARK MANDEL: In
theory, it was doable.
You could store
the data in Redis.
I wanted to make it
as fast as possible,
and so I kept a lot
of it in memory.
But in theory, you
could do that, too.
That would work as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: My question was
not only about the data itself
but also about
where-- how do you
handle that connection,
that streaming?
Can you handle that stream
across different containers?
MARK MANDEL: So right
now, the way it works
is that connection,
it actually--
the way the game
is coded is such
that when that connection
declares that's the game,
and as long as that
connection is live,
it makes things very simple.
In theory, you could
also do something
like with every request, send
a game ID across the board.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
this is the game.
So if I'm attached to this,
this is the message I'm sending.
But it ended up being
simpler this way,
with a single connection,
because then you
knew if there was
something coming
up and down this particular
bidirectional stream,
we knew it had to
do with that game.
Otherwise, authentication
gets a little bit more tricky,
and there's a few
other security issues--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, you're basically
trading on a little
bit of flexibility
on the how flexible it is to
errors and downtime to the fact
that it is super
comfortable to just use
a little bit of
statefulness there.
And everything is so
much easier, cool.
MARK MANDEL: Everything
is much easier.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, thank you so much for
taking the time to tell me
a little bit about Simon Says.
And we'll definitely
have a bunch
of links on the show notes to
all the code and the blog post
you mentioned.
And also, I think, you gave
talks about this, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we've both done several.
SANDEEP DINESH: Multiple talks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
we'll have some of the talks
so people can have a look and
see what the game actually
looks like, which
is actually-- I
really like the
lunchbox with buttons.
I think it's really cool.
SANDEEP DINESH: Yeah, I
think the funniest thing--
just to end on-- I think
me and you, Mark, have only
given this talk together once.
MARK MANDEL: It's true.
SANDEEP DINESH: Even though
we built it together,
which is just how
their lives work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we'll
try to have a link to that one,
then.
OK, well, thank you very much.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much.
SANDEEP DINESH: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Well, thank you
so much to Sandeep and well,
myself, for coming
on the podcast
today and talking about Simon,
and gRPC, and Kubernetes.
And Francesc, I hope
you learned a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
I actually learned a lot.
It was very interesting.
I always like asking
questions of people
that know their things.
And also it was
nice to talk to you.
So yeah.
No, just kidding.
It was very interesting.
I'm actually very interested
on taking up the source code
because it is really
cool the fact that you're
doing so many
different languages
and just because
you're using gRPC.
The communication
is just obvious.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it just works.
SANDEEP DINESH:
That's pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: It's
really, really cool.
All right, I think we have
a guest coming for-- that
might be outside now.
Hold on, let's just have a look.
[KNOCK ON DOOR]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, guys.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, how doing?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You recording
a podcast or something in here?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, kind of.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Mind
if I crash the party?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Please join.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Hey, everybody,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, Timothy
Jordon from the Developer Show,
just crashing our Podcast.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's what we do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep,
how are you doing?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm doing great.
I hear that you guys have
a question of the week,
and I would like
to ask a question.
MARK MANDEL: Please,
please go right ahead.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
so on the Developer Show,
we've been talking a lot about
machine learning recently.
And a lot of developers
know that TensorFlow
is a fast, flexible,
and scalable open source
machine learning framework.
But what they don't
all seem to know
is that you can train
and run TensorFlow models
on Google Cloud Platform.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about the details there?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So I think that what
you are referring to
is what we call the Google
Cloud Machine Learning
platform, Cloud ML for short.
And, basically, it allows
you to train models
on the Google Cloud Platform
infrastructure, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
that's, I think,
really key, because once you
get into machine learning pretty
deeply, your data is so large
and training takes so long
on your desktop at
home, that having
a scalable infrastructure to
train on becomes critical.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it is
definitely very, very important
if you're going to
start training models.
So you've got to start
with either your own model
or choose one from the
TensorFlow framework, which,
is open source.
And then you're going to
need to train those models.
And no matter how big
the data you're using is,
you're going to be able to do
that on managed and completely
scalable infrastructure
on Google Cloud Platform.
And then once
you're done, you're
going to be able to serve
those training models,
so you can do predictions
based on that with live traffic
again, on Google Cloud ML.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
It's also worth noting, though,
if like machine learning isn't
particularly your thing,
we have pre-baked services
that you can use.
So we have the Vision API,
speech, natural language
processing, and the
Translation API.
These are REST APIs
that have already
had all the machine
learning, training,
and research all done for you.
And they're a REST
endpoint, so if you
can call a REST endpoint
from any language,
you can use those things.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, I will
consider my question answered.
Thank you, gentlemen.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Awesome, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
I'll let you get back to your
regularly scheduled podcast.
MARK MANDEL: See ya.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: See you guys.
MARK MANDEL: So
now Timothy Jordan,
the host of the Developer
Show, has left the studio.
Francesc, where are you going?
What are you doing?
Is there a Just
for Funk coming up?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
actually working on the next
Just for Funk, which it's going
to be somehow released probably
by the end of this week, maybe
next one, which is pretty cool.
And maybe I will maybe go
see you speak this weekend.
Where are you speaking again?
MARK MANDEL: So I will be at
the Silicon Valley DevFest
down in Mountain
View this weekend.
I am doing, funnily enough,
the Simon Says talk.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, be talking
about gRPC and Kubernetes
and some fun IoT stuff, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Are you
going to have your lunchbox
with buttons with you?
MARK MANDEL: I will
definitely have my lunchbox
with buttons with me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is awesome.
Cool.
Well, thank you so much
today for not only being
the host but also the guest.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
I appreciate being here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And talk to
you and to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]